m night shyamalan's latest film is here
and has finally encapsulated what i feel
when i log on to tik tok
old is a sci-fi thriller and in the
tradition of great shyamalan films like
the sixth sense and unbreakable
has an insane twist ending so in this
video we'll be taking a deep dive into
that twist and some of the intricate
details you may have missed along the
way
spoilers ahead for those who haven't
seen the movie and if you like these
videos make sure to like and subscribe
or leave a comment
every interaction helps me in the
channel welcome to the animika resort a
luxury paradise where our protagonists
sit back and relax before making their
way to the mysterious secluded beach
animeka is derived from hindu meaning
without a name or
anonymous and considering the resort's
secretive nature it's no wonder why it's
given that name we're quickly introduced
to married couple guy
and prisca as well as their two children
maddox and trent
prisca is a variant of priscilla from
latin which means
ancient a fitting name for a character
in a movie called
old priska found this resort online but
as we'll later find out there is
something
far more nefarious going on here it's
never explicitly said in the film
where this resort is however hawaiian
music plays in the background suggesting
it could be in the south pacific
we do know that the film was shot in the
dominican republic where they actually
constructed a
giant rock wall on the beach which had
to be rebuilt multiple times since they
shot during the hurricane season upon
their arrival the guests are given
specialty cocktails specifically crafted
to match their beverage preferences but
these cocktails serve a far more evil
purpose as we'll find out in the film's
final act trent the six-year-old makes
friends with idlib whose uncle runs the
resort like most kids they spend their
time making up games like going around
the resort asking people their names and
what they do for a living this game
along with the cryptogram idlib gives
trent before heading off to the beach
proved to be very important near the end
of the film at breakfast we're
introduced
to more of the cast charles a doctor his
trophy wife crystal
cara their daughter and agnes charles's
mother the breakfast is interrupted
however when fellow guest patricia
experiences a seizure she's lucky to
have her nurse husband jaren by her side
everything in the first 20 minutes is
setting up what will be a big payoff
near the end of the film
we also learned that everything isn't
sunshine and rainbows in guy and
prisca's marriage
in fact this is the last trip they're
taking with their kids before they
separate prisca
cheated on guy and has also been
diagnosed with a benign tumor putting
added strain on the relationship there's
also an interesting talk about how
prisca always lives in the past
she is a museum curator by the way and
guy is always thinking ahead to the
future
neither of them are living in the
present and that's a theme shyamalan
wanted to hit in this movie all of these
problems for them all of the thriller
problems all of the personal problems
and the answer is ultimately just being
present speaking of the director he has
a much larger cameo in the film than he
usually does in his past movies acting
as the van driver who brings the
families to this mysterious secluded
beach
but he's not just a van driver more on
that
later so charles and guy's family at the
insistence of the hotel manager make
their way to this gorgeous beach
surrounded by cascading cliffs
the only way to reach it is through this
narrow rocky corridor they're also given
an
insane amount of food to carry which
they think is odd but
actually serves a vital purpose later in
the story the beach is a definite hit
with the kids even though there are old
rusty cutlery and knickknacks from what
appears to be previous resort guests
littered all over it and everything
seems to be going great until a dead
body washes the shore next to trent this
is the girlfriend of another person
we'll meet on the beach
a rapper known by the name midsize sedan
yeah that's his name he says she went
out swimming and must have lost
consciousness but charles who's a raging
racist in the graphic novel the movie is
based on
suspects the rapper of foul play but
before anything can really be resolved
charles's mother begins to experience
chest pains jiren goes to get help
heading back through that rocky corridor
but after experiencing tremendous head
pressure falls unconscious and wakes up
on the beach
from here on out things start happening
really fast
trenton maddox who arrived on the beach
as ages 6 and 11
have now aged about 6 years in only a
matter of hours we'll later find out by
prisco's estimation that one hour on the
beach is about two years in reality
making one day on the beach almost a
lifetime time here works differently
aging anything in its sphere of
influence at a rapid pace
what's worse there's no way out heading
back the way they came in results in
passing out
the rock face is too steep to climb and
the water too dangerous to traverse
so our beach dwellers need to find a
different way of escape
at first the adults believe it's only
the kids who are reacting to the
mysterious
influence of the beach that's because
they're still growing their changes are
far more visible than those of the
adults that's also why so much food was
given to them the energy needed to
sustain their growth is insane while the
adults aren't growing physically they're
just growing old
in a heated confrontation between
charles and midsize sedan charles cuts
sedan's face into everyone's shock
the cut heals immediately if things
happen really fast here then it's
logical to assume healing must also
occur fast and that's exactly what
happens sedan says his girlfriend had ms
and the island healed her so she went
out for a swim and that's when she died
and sedan is vindicated when her body
which was a few hours ago laying on the
beach
has completely turned into bone
decomposition is something that's
supposed to take roughly seven years and
this happened in the span of a few hours
prisca's tumor which was previously
benign has started to grow
before arriving on the island it was
three centimeters in diameter but now
it's the size of a cantaloupe carl's has
to perform
surgery on her but since the body heals
at a rapid rate the other beach dwellers
must keep their hands inside the
incision
as he performs the surgery to prevent
the body from closing and healing it
what makes this scene even more intense
is that charles seems to be losing his
memory he constantly asks the others
what movie starred jack nicholson
and marlon brando by the way it's 1976's
the missouri breaks at this point you
may be realizing that many of the
characters on the beach
suffer from either a physical or mental
illness the characters have also spotted
reflections of what appear to be cameras
on the heels of the surrounding cliffs
they're being watched but by who and why
jaren surmises that the reason they fall
unconscious when they try to leave is
that they aren't acclimatized it's like
when you're really deep in the ocean and
come up too fast you can get the bends
trent will later find a journal left
behind from a previous beachgoer that
says
if they could construct some sort of
metal tube to deflect the magnetism of
the beach
they might be able to get out without
falling unconscious
the only problem is beaches don't tend
to have giant metal tubes lying around
kara and trent have now grown up and
imagined going through puberty in a span
of two
hours although their bodies have
developed their brains haven't caught up
and the two given to their primal sexual
urges
and have sex without really knowing what
they're doing so kind of like my first
time
remember neither of them have been given
the birds and the bees talk this results
in one of the most terrifying scenes of
the film in which cara becomes
pregnant and gives birth in a matter of
minutes her baby ends up dying
unable to withstand the rapid pace of
its growth and there's this morbid scene
where cara holds her dead baby which is
already dissolved into bone and ash
with nowhere left to go kara attempts to
climb the rocky cliff and escape
but dies in the process jiren tries to
swim his way out but he
too washes a short dead then there's
charles whose mental illness has turned
him violent and a danger to everyone on
the beach
the group also realizes that it was no
coincidence they all
ended up here they believed they were
chosen and manipulated into coming
whether it be through an online
sweepstakes or
other enticement patricia having lost
her husband decides to leave as well but
before she does she experiences one of
her seizures which kills her
but keep in mind it's been several hours
the equivalent of
decades on the beach since she's had a
seizure that point will become
important later on as time goes by guy
starts to lose his eyesight and prisca
her hearing they're getting old
it's only by the two of them living in
the present that they begin to patch up
their relationship
and forgive each other as night time
hits charles who has gone full jack
torns in the shining attacks
but as he stabs guy and prisca their
wounds immediately heal it's kinda crazy
it's only when prisca slashes charles
with a rusty knife the same kind we saw
earlier on the beach that they're able
to stop him
because the rust contains bacteria that
enters the bloodstream
even if that wound heals the bacteria
will continue to surge through the blood
essentially giving him a case of rapid
tetanus
meanwhile maddox and trent hide out in
the cave were crystal that woman
obsessed with her looks has basically
turned into an
ugly hunchback in the beginning of the
movie we hear she has a calcium
deficiency so her bones break easily and
in one of the most effed up scenes of
the movie
we see her body and bones contort like a
cirque du soleil performer until she
gruesomely dies
with charles and crystal out of the
picture the only thing left is to make
it off the beach
there's a fun callback when older maddox
sings to her mother when earlier in the
film when
maddox was younger the mother said i'd
love to hear you sing when you're older
eventually guy and prisca succumb to
their old age
leaving fully grown adults trent and
maddox the only two left
trent remembers that young boy from the
resort left him a cryptogram before he
left and since they're going to die on
that beach they might as well solve it
well it ends up containing a clue that
might just save them after decoding the
puzzle it reveals the phrase
my uncle doesn't like the coral perhaps
something in the nearby coral negates
the power of the beach
so the two of them head over and what do
they find the coral has created an
underwater tube that could possibly
protect them from the beach's powers
as they make their escape meanwhile
shyamalan watches their escape in the
water but
after seeing them not emerge writes them
off as dead this is where the real twist
of the movie is revealed the van driver
works for a pharmaceutical company
called warren and warren not sure if
that's supposed to be a take on johnson
and johnson
he alerts the lab which also happens to
be at the resort that the last remaining
subjects of trial 73 have
perished and he'll be returning back
with the data so at least 73 versions of
human subjects being brought to the
beach have already occurred and as new
guests are greeted to the resort we know
trial 74
is on its way because the island allows
a human to live out their entire life in
roughly a day
it means clinical trials to test a
drug's efficacy can be done
in that time instead of years that's why
many of the beach subjects had physical
or mental illnesses
those specialty cocktails they were
given at the beginning contained the
treatment for their respective ailment
whether it be dementia
cancer or seizures and remember how
patricia survived multiple hours without
a seizure
her treatment was deemed a success the
pharmaceutical company had successfully
found a treatment in preventing seizures
at the expense of patricia's life they
also saved years
in research trials as one of the pharma
company's members says it's worth
sacrificing these subjects in order for
hundreds of thousands to survive
but the final twist is that trent and
manix have also survived making their
way back to the resort remember when
trent was a kid and he asked some of the
resort patrons what they do
well one of them was a cop for the cop
it's only been a day but for trent he's
grown
40 plus years trent hands over that
journal which also has the names and
addresses of previous trial subjects
thereby exposing warren and warren the
resort is locked down
the bad guys arrested and trenton maddox
go off to live with their aunt
who they are now physically older than
it's truly a wild
ride but what did you think of old was
warren and warren justified in their
trials and what would you do
if you found yourself on this speech i
want to hear your comments below
thanks for watching everyone remember to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can always follow me on
twitter and instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much